hello everyone and welcome today I am
going to go over a few things you can do
to improve your imaging experiment and
also tell you about some different
reagents that can help in experimental
design and also in choosing what
reagents you would might want to use to
ask for your scientific questions so
those three main things that I'd like to
cover today are go over some of the
basic reasons you might want to use
fluorescence in your microscopy
experiments bring out some common
problems that both experts and even
beginners run into and different ways
that you can solve those problems
science is mostly about iteration it's
about 1% inspiration 99% iteration so
we'll go over some tips and tricks and
then reagents and instruments that can
also help with some of those problems
and then lastly if I don't talk too much
I'll mention a few online resources that
thermo Fisher has that can give you some
of the material you see today and also
some apps for your phone that can help
with experimental design and protocols
so a brief history of molecular probes
it was founded by a chemist in Minnesota
in his kitchen and then they moved to
Texas in the late 70s and started a
company there and you'll see some of the
place names from where he moved around
the country in the names of the dyes for
instance Texas red and then he relocated
to Oregon and a place near Eugene which
is where we're located now and so you'll
sometimes see some of the names like
Oregon Green is a common dining that
Propst catalog contains but but really
the more famous dyes and probes that
were known for were developed in the 90s
and those include the my toe trackers
lyso trackers flow for a and things like
that and we'll go over some of them
today we've gone through a few different
corporation parent corporation name
changes in vitro jen acquired molecular
probes and then emerged with a bi and we
were known as life technologies but now
we've been acquired by a thermo Fisher
and that's our parent corporation those
phone numbers you see on your screen our
phone numbers the 800 number is directly
to molecular probes technical support
and the 541 number is if you wanted to
talk to a real person at our front desk
so why do we use fluorescence in
microscopy one of the big reasons we use
it is for resolution the modern CCD
cameras that acquire the images that we
usually acquire in fluorescence
microscopy have a much bigger range in
their both the wavelengths that and
their sensitivity so what you see here
is under the blue peak is what the human
eye can generally see if you're young
you can see all the way out to 700
nanometers usually older eyes like mine
can't even see that far and it cuts off
somewhere in the 600's but you can see
that CCD cameras can see a much long
wide range of wavelengths and that helps
and they're also much more efficient in
terms of how many photons they need to
see detect a signal so resolution is one
of the main reasons we would use
fluorescence microscopy
another reason is selectivity so what
you can see in this side is in this
slide is a the same flora for which is
that green blob labeled flora flora and
it's conjugated to different things
and that's what provides specificity for
where it goes in the cell so in the
first example it's conjugated this floor
is conjugated to a molecule that targets
actin and you can see an example of what
it looks like when you label actin and
green in the little picture below in the
middle example the floor floor has been
conjugated to an antibody and then you
can see that usually there's secondary
antibodies and you can see in the
picture below what's happened when
you've used immuno labeling to deliver
that fluorescent signal and then the
last example which is a little less
common today but it still gets used is
is where you deliver the floor for to
the internal area of the cell maybe by
injection and that's usually when the
floor floor is in a salt form and you
can look at trap you know look at cell
processes and how they grow so those are
all the same floors and and they just
change in their selectivity with how
they're conjugated or how they're
applied to the cell so that's another
really convenient feature for
fluorescence microscopy another big one
which you're seeing in the slide here is
the contrast that fluorescent labeling
provides so when you look at that
transmitted light image you can see that
you get some detail but not a lot and if
you label the nucleus and the actin
filaments with fluorescent labels you
get a lot more contrast between them and
their surroundings so you get a more a
better picture of the structures inside
and outside of the cell when you use
fluorescent labels so for example this
is just another picture that shows you
what something looks like these cells
are proliferating and this is in bright
field and then if you were to look at it
with labels delivered to the golgi and
the nucleus you could see that you can
see that the nucleus is here in green
the golgi is in red and you get
a lot more information than you did just
with right field so with any advantage
there always are costs associated with
it and science is no exception
some common issues that people run into
when they use fluorescent microscopy can
include background fluorescence we're
going to spend quite a bit of time
talking about ways to improve your
signal to background which dyes and
reagents to choose sometimes you might
run into problems where your cells seem
to be dying once you put them on the
microscope or you might have
experimental questions about how many
cells are dead how many are alive little
we'll go over some reagents that can
help there and then there's also issues
of photo toxicity we we're going to
explain what photo toxicity is and some
ways to avoid it
same with photo bleaching and other
common problems so signal to background
is really the name of the game when it
comes to a successful fluorescent
imaging experiment and the way we define
signal and background is we say signal
is the fluorescent probe giving you a
signal from where you want it to be so
if you have a specific probe it's the
fluorescence you want to see background
is basically fluorescence from
everywhere else and it can be non mostly
non specific background fluorescence and
it can come from a variety of places in
your experiment and that's what this
little cartoon is showing you so it can
come from the media that your cells are
in when you do your imaging experiment
it can come from the vessel it can come
sometimes from the reagents that you use
or even your sample this is especially
problematic in tissue where they have it
has a lot of autofluorescence so we'll
go over briefly go over a few different
ways to kind of work around the
background fluorescence in each of these
areas
so that your signal is nice and bright
and you can do a successful experiment
first of all before you get started just
make sure your microscope is functioning
properly that might be really basic but
it's key and what you're seeing here you
might think oh that you're looking at
these blue blobs are nuclei that are
labeled with a fluorescent probe Herc's
and you might think that over there in
the corner where it's very dim that it's
just a really low signal and somehow
they were labeled unevenly but that's
not the case what happened here was that
the microscope was not in alignment and
so this meant that the picture looked
dimmer in some areas and brighter and
others and it was due to just the light
was didn't have a clear path so make
sure your microscopes functioning
properly and if you have a question
about it if you're just beginning
you might ask somebody else look at
something that you think should have a
really good label make sure that all the
field of view has the same amount of
signal before you start to troubleshoot
your actual experimental design another
thing that people don't always like to
hear but it's actually pretty important
is that usually when you purchase a dye
to use on yourselves our range of
concentrations are given and that's
because the optimal concentration for
your particular cell or tissue may not
be the same as someone else's so what
you really need to do if you're having
problems with signal and background is
to optimize your dye concentration and
what you're seeing here in this series
of panels is that concentration can
really matter the one that's labeled 1x
is the optimal amount of signal to
background and you can see in the the
next panel which should be labeled 4x I
apologize it somehow the concentrations
got changed on the bottom there but in
the bottom panel there then that is it
looks like your signals brighter but the
background has also increased
so in fact it's not the best
concentration to be using and then if
you go all the way up to 12x you can see
that the the background is even visible
to you are I not just to the camera and
that that would not be a good
concentration to use either so
optimizing your diet concentration
checking a series a range of
concentrations can be helpful if you're
running into either low signal or really
high background another thing to do when
you're in the experimental design
portion of your your your experiment is
make sure that your floor floors are the
best match to the filters on your
microscope and that can prevent what we
refer to as bleed through and what
you're showing here what you're seeing
here in this black and white picture is
a label that was used and it was
intended to be to label something that
would show up in the trixie channel and
what happened was because the dye was
had such a broad emission spectrum it
actually did what we call bleed through
to another Channel the fitzy channel and
it's not pseudo colored but you're just
having a look at it from the from just
the image that the camera records and
you can see that those actin filaments
are actually showing up in a channel
they weren't intended to and that could
also give you background fluorescence
when in an area you didn't want so in
the next slide just a reminder that if
you are using immuno labeling where you
use antibodies generally an imaging you
use a primary antibody against your
epitope and then a secondary antibody
that has the floor floor conjugated on
it and you just want to avoid having
more than one primary antibody raised in
the same host species if you're doing
multicolor with many different
antibodies
in the next slide I'm showing you a few
different pictures of imaging vessels
and so if you want your best like cover
of the journal quality fluorescent image
you're going to want to use glass and
that can be challenging sometimes cells
don't always like to grow on glass and
when you're doing in life cells you want
your cells happy as well so so that you
know you have to be the best judge of
when when you want to use the glass I
mean a lot of times if you look at that
orange lidded flask many times you're
checking cells in the actual tissue
culture vessel that's it's they're
commonly grown in that plastic is fine
for growing cells it's great and it will
work for quick checks but if you want a
really high-quality image you're going
to have to culture yourselves on glass
and that's because if you look in the
little cartoon at high magnification and
high resolution the glass is the best
match for immersion oils that a lot of
high magnification objectives use
because the the refractive index is
matched the oil to the glass to the
optics in your objective so you'll just
get the best image there if you use a
glass vessel and someone I really like
to use are these little round ones that
you see so they're they're plastic which
makes it easier to handle but then they
have a glass bottom in them and you can
see that those nunc ones are quite handy
another thing to use if you're trying to
do a lot of experiments at the same time
is a 96-well plate that you can see in
the middle there in that top panel and
just some things to remember there if
you're using 96 full plates you want to
use probably black plastic because it
tends to have less other fluorescents
than white and you want to use glass
bottom ones that will give you a better
image so I'm kind of changing tact a
little bit if you've taken care of the
and the culturing vessel another thing
to think about is what solution your
cells are being imaged in if you're
doing a live cell experiment and
something to consider is to not image
them in their culturing media because
culturing media tends to have a lot of
fluorescent compounds in it that will
give you background when you're trying
to look at your specific fluorescence
signal so one thing that you can use is
something that we sell called a live
cell imaging solution it's a product
that I developed and it's based on
ringers solution ringers is like is a
very old recipe that physiologists have
used since the 1800s it's also what you
get and if you go to the hospital and
you have an IV it's it's very related to
to that drips that goes into your but
it's very physiological the nice thing
about it is is optically clear and it
will keep yourselves very healthy well
they're on the microscope but the caveat
there is that it's really best for
experiments that get done in four hours
or less if you want something where
you're following an experiment you're
following cells out and you want to
image them for some reason it's
important that you image them in the
same media that they were cultured in
then the suggestion there is to use a
diamond media that was developed to be
as optically inert as possible and
that's that flow bright media that
you're seeing on the slide there it what
you can see from the data there it
supports proliferation of cells so they
proliferate and grow normally but the
background fluorescence is much lower
than demon it's comparable to PBS or
another saline solution and so your
signal-to-noise is comparable to PBS
which you don't get when you image in
or other media's like that but it can
also support proliferation and and
normal cell function that goes on over a
process of four hours or longer and then
and so then in the the next slide what
what we're kind of addressing now are
all the different questions you can ask
about how healthy your cells are and you
may be asking these questions because
you are studying a process that involves
cell viability or proliferation or a
ptosis or you might be asking these
questions because you want to make sure
that your experimental technique isn't
changing or biasing your results in
terms of are yourselves still healthy
when they're on the microscope and
you're studying them and so something to
understand is really when we talk about
fluorescent imaging what we mean by a
live cell and what we mean by a dead
cell so what makes a cell alive is is a
philosophical question really and it
could be debated and has been but when
it comes to fluorescent reagents the way
we define a live cell is a cell whose
membrane is intact and it has enzymes
that can support the the cleavage of a
dye that when it's in its native form
it's not fluorescent but then by by
enzymes that all cells contain it could
something gets cleaved off and it
becomes fluorescent so that we take as
our live readout and then for a dead
readout that would be the case from a
from a basic fluorescent imaging
perspective where a in permeate no clay
ik acid so it normally cannot cross a
healthy cell membrane but when cells die
their membranes become hermia so you
would get a signal from your nucleus
if you were using a dead cell indicator
that showed that that nucleic acid was
able to bind DNA and fluoresce and it
couldn't do that if the cell membrane
was healthy and intact so that that's
kind of important to keep in mind when
you're thinking about live cell
indicators and dead cell indicators
lifestyle indicators are things that
usually rely on an enzyme substrate in
your cell and dead cell indicators are
usually things that are in permeant
nucleic acid dyes that are able to get
to the nucleic acid in the cell's
nucleus because the cell is sick or
dying and it's membrane is no longer
intact so one thing that that people run
into problems with is a lot of live dead
imaging kits don't fit into filter sets
very well they're because they're based
on flow cytometry who tend to have a
different filter setup but we do have
one that's ideal for fitzy and Texas red
filters and you can see this beautiful
image of a green live cells that means
that enzyme is active in those cells and
so they're fluorescent green and they're
the dead cells where the membranes are
permanent to nucleic acid dyes are
showing up as those red nuclei and I
think that in the next movie that's
played you can actually see a movie of
how the the cells would look if you were
looking in the ocular and they started
out healthy and then died
you
you
you
so what you saw there was that the cell
started out green and health that was
their lifestyle indication and then what
we did at the microscope is we actually
poisoned them we pipette it in a bunch
of DMSO that basically blew up their
membranes and killed them and you saw
that loss of green fluorescence and then
the red indication that the cells were
officially dead and so that's kind of
the sort of thing that was a very
dramatic example but that's the sort of
thing that you could expect to see if
you use a live dead imaging kit with
those fitzy and Texas red filter
selections so in the next slide we're
going to explain a little bit about
indicators for a puto --ss which is
another you know this particular way
that cells can die is through an abiotic
pathway and Sullivan caspase-3 7 is a
reagent that it's it's dark it has no
fluorescence until an enzyme is
activated in the a protonic pathway
caspase-3 7 that's the enzyme and when
that happens it Cleaves off a peptide
off of this dye and then it causes the
dye which is a DNA dye to be free and
able to bind to DNA and so when you
cleave off that peptide the DNA the DNA
dye can go and bind to DNA and what you
see in no treatment is dark but when the
cells have been induced with able to
become a patate ik with stores foreign
what you see there is that you get that
green indicator that tells you those
cells are undergoing a B ptosis and it's
a readout in particular of the caspase
37 pathway so if you wanted to multiplex
it with something like TMR M TMR M is a
mitochondrial health readout and you can
see at zero hour
the cells are label
with Radames of those red spots you see
and that means their mitochondria are
all intact and functioning but when the
cells are treated with stores born to
evoke a pitocin you can see that by
about three hours the red signals all
gone because the mitochondria are no
longer healthy so they've lost that that
signal of mitochondrial health and by
seven hours most of the cells are green
showing that they've undergone a pitocin
and that's that cell event signal so um
the settlement and a few of our other
reagents are actually available in a
dropper bottle format that you can keep
on your lab bench and all the protocols
are the same you just drop in two drops
per mil and you can look for those under
the ready probes reagent if you search
for that you'll find that on our website
and that includes cell event and some of
the other nucleic acid dyes so another
common question when it comes to self
health is oxidative stress oxidative
stress is reactive oxygen species that
get generated through a variety of ways
and we have a few really nice probes to
ask questions about whether your cells
are undergoing oxidative stress or not
the one you're looking at here is cell
Roxby bread and what you can see on the
top panel are the nuclei in control
those are blue nuclei and then what you
see when the cells are treated with
something that evokes hypoxia and they
so when they're in hypoxia they undergo
that oxidative stress and they generate
a lot of reactive oxygen species so then
you see that that little pinkish red
signal show up and what you see in the
bottom panel is that it that signal is
retained if you want to fix yourselves
afterwards which makes it convenient to
do a live cell imaging expert
and then fix it and retain the signal
and you can also get this is a far-red
sensor which is nice when you're you
know working in tissue or other things
that the green channel is being used but
they're also available in green and
orange wavelengths as well and I think
that the next slide is a movie where you
can see cell rock screen so what you'll
see is that the cells will start out
with no color but as they undergo
oxidative stress they'll become green
so that happened pretty fast but
hopefully you got the idea it's
sometimes nice to see them in instead of
just pictures to see the kind of time
time frame you're talking about in a
live image so another common question to
ask about yourselves or tissue is what's
proliferating and EDU is a pretty common
way you use a modified uracil that that
labels DNA while DNA is being made and
that would be while your cells are
proliferating and then it gets
incorporated into the DNA and you can
label that special those special sugars
that got incorporated into the DNA while
the cells were proliferating and the
nice thing about the product that we
call click it edu is that it's not
radioactive so you can look at
proliferation fluorescently and it's
really a nice simple protocol because
you can see here the the what be what
click it edu takes the place of is
what's referred to as a brdu protocol
and that can take all day whereas the
click at edu is nice because you do
there you feed the cells they
proliferate and then the actual hands-on
work is about an hour and you get a
really nice readout in fluorescent
microscopy or flow or high-throughput
imaging of which cells are proliferating
and which are not but one of the issues
with click it was that a lot of people
like to use GFP and green fluorescent
protein to label structures in their
cell and with classic brdu and click it
edu what you see there in that upper
panel is that you lose your GFP signal
base is due to the chemical components
of the reactions where you label that
DNA it kills the GFP signal so a lot of
customers talked to us and said you know
we really would like to be able to look
at proliferation using this
non-radioactive quick way but we want to
be able to see our GFP signal as well so
a colleague of mine developed click it
plus edu and that's where the the
reaction has been reformulated it
preserves the GFP signal and the edu
signal and that's what you're seeing in
that third panel you're seeing the
nuclei in blue it's a little hard to see
but I think I think you can see them and
then you're seeing the GFP labeled cells
in green and you're seeing the cells
that were proliferating at the time they
were fixed in red so you can see you get
all of the signals you want whereas in
the other two panels the brdu and the
classic click that you lost your GFP
signal that that last panel is just a
control showing you that on the click at
signal is in fact real and if you take
away the copper that's necessary to
catalyze that reaction then you lose
your edu signal so a nice thing about
click it is that is a very specific
readout of cell proliferation and it
works across almost every species that's
been tested and you're seeing just a
nice example of a bunch of different
species here from zebrafish to Mouse and
so it checks ecoli it basically has
worked in almost every species and
kingdom that that's been tested in so on
this slide is here to remind me that to
talk about once your cells are out of
the incubator and you're putting them on
the stage of the microscope to do your
live cell imaging experiment
and it can be a very harsh environment
for cells they're used to being in the
incubator they're they're used to their
media being a certain pH they're used to
a certain amount of co2 and oxygen and
so when you take them out of that
incubator and put them on the microscope
you have to be sure to do some things to
accommodate them and control their
environment and because if you don't
it's kind of like asking you to get on
that frozen bicycle and start writing
like you were writing on a nice summer
day and we can imagine how that would go
so one of the problems the slide always
kind of makes me a little sad as an
electrophysiologist who did two
full-time imaging but it's true there
are usually a lot of steps involved in
doing high resolution lifestyle imaging
a lot and you know I think this is 11 or
12 steps and people can get pretty
intimidated using it and trying to keep
yourselves healthy and do all of the the
things you need to do to use this
instrument so there are instruments that
to be honest I was a little skeptical of
when I first started using them but now
I love them and I'm a big fan these are
digital microscopes that are really easy
to use there's not 11 steps or 12 steps
to turn it on you can you can do phase
you can do fluorescence microscopy and
it's nice because they're LED powered so
you have less photo bleaching in your
experiments which is good and my one of
my favorite things about them my
favorite one is the FL Auto and the
reason I love it is because I'm a
physiologist
and I love that you can get an on-stage
incubator that's pretty nice and simple
to use and that gets us back to that's
why we're going here you get you can put
yourselves in that nice controlled
environment so you can regulate the
temperature that he
how much oxygen they're getting and it's
all right there on the stage of the
microscope and it you can control it
digitally while you're you know setting
up your experiment and it's a really
nice feature I even like it better now
than my twelve step confocal but
something else that's worth mentioning
just about the FL Auto is that you can
get more than one kind of camera so you
can get color and monochrome cameras and
that that can be really important when
you're imaging tissue and then it also
does what we call image stitching where
it takes a series of images of something
really big and can stitch them together
to give you a complete image of
something at you know magnification that
normally you couldn't collect all the
images of and that's really taking
advantage of the fact that it's a
digital microscope but now back to the
hard stuff so one of the challenges of
live cell imaging is photo toxicity and
that is something that that you'll see
if you do live cell imaging and you kind
of have to learn about it the hard way
what you can see here this is in a
couple of different examples what you
can see on the top panel that gray and
green image is that if you look to the
right where it says illuminated area you
can see that the green signal is pretty
dim and I don't know if you can see it
at a resolution on your computer but
you'll have to take my word for it the
cells are really unhealthy looking the
membranes look terrible probably if you
had a dead cell indicator in there it
would be screaming red because those
cells have all died and what you see in
the non illuminated area is that you
have a nice bright green fluorescent
signal from your GFP labeled nuclei and
the cells are happy and thriving and and
sometimes people think that that's from
you know the expression of a probe or or
labeling with a dye
it's really not it's it's from the
actual light that you shine on your
cells to get the very images you want
can be toxic to cells and that's because
most cells are not intended to ever see
light the way we do when we interrogate
them on a microscope so they it's
something to be aware of and if you look
in the bottom panel um you're looking at
some fibroblast cells that had some
scratch wounds scratched across them and
then what and they're labeled with cell
tracker deep red and then and then it's
just showing you and you're gonna have
to ignore the the the titles on the
bottom there because they got flipped
and I'm sorry
wait what you're looking at in that
scratch where there's basically a tunnel
through the cells the cells are shown in
red and they didn't ever grow back into
that scratch wound and that's because
they were under illumination so they had
gone undergone time-lapse imaging for
dinner ten hours and it wasn't the probe
itself that that caused that photo
toxicity because if you look in the non
illuminated area the cells have grown
back into the wound and you can see that
that they're they're proliferating and
they're healthy
so that that's photo toxicity and what
that is is it's so do deaths that's
induced by light exposure it tends to be
independent of fluorescent labels they
can contribute to some of the on
toxicities associated with light but you
can you can cause your cells harm just
by shining light on them with no
fluorescent label at all and and the
what the things you should watch out for
when you're doing your lifestyle imaging
experiment our seen cells round up art
and detach flowed off of the the
culturing vessel if if you're used to
watching them move and grow and that
and growth slows and where you tend to
see these problems is when you're doing
life cells when you're doing time lapses
that are that are over a long periods of
time
so what can you do to to get around that
well first of all you can make sure that
your cell environment is as comfortable
for the cell as possible and that goes
back to making sure that it's in you
know a solution that's physiological
it's the right pH it's warm you know you
have that on stage incubator to keep
yourselves happy but then when it comes
to actually doing the imaging you
there's also a few things to keep in
mind if you see photo toxicity you could
use shorter exposure times and so you
know a lot of times we want to expose
for as long as possible to get the
highest quality image but when it comes
to time law
time lapse microscopy you might need to
cut back on your exposure time so that
the amount of light that those cells see
over time is lessened you also as much
as autofocus is nice to use to find your
focal plane you probably don't want to
do your time lapse where you've used the
autofocus you want to minimize that as
much as possible for those overnight or
long time lapse experiments because
autofocus eeeem uses a lot of light so
the cells only can you know have so much
light shine on them and if you use that
up with your autofocus by the time you
do your actual experiment the cells will
be pretty unhealthy another thing to do
is to use optimal filters and we talked
about that a little bit you want to make
sure that that you're using the right
filter set so that you're harvesting as
much of the signal as possible it'll
mean you can use shorter exposure times
you also might think about if you're
trying to image overnight or a whole day
you would might think nuc photo toxicity
you might want to think about increasing
the interval between the times you take
images so not only shortening the
time that you expose the cells to light
and get your image but also lengthening
the amount of time in between images in
your time-lapse and the last thing you
can do is around dye selection so
basically the brighter the dye the
shorter the exposure time and the and a
dye matched to its filter will also
allow you to have much shorter exposure
times so what are some common really
bright dyes that are good to use when
we're trying to do cell biology
lifestyle on live cell imaging organelle
tracker dyes are nice because they are
very bright and specific you can see
them here labeling the golgi in red and
in each case the nucleus is labeled in
blue lysosomes can be labeled using
these tracker dyes mitochondria we saw
some of the we saw TMR em with the
mitochondrial self health indicator and
then the ER can be labeled as well so
those are nice bright reagents to try if
you're another thing to think about when
you're designing your experiment is that
is is that if you've got Auto
fluorescents or you're having problems
with photo toxicity you can try imaging
out in longer wavelengths those have
less energy associated with them and
sometimes they can help with your photo
toxicity issues so here just for example
is lie so tracker and it's in a deep red
so that would be a you know a long
longer wavelength red indicator another
way to label cells organelles and
structures is to use genetically encoded
labels and that takes advantage of
fluorescent proteins and you can send
the fluorescent proteins to different
structures in the cell the hard part
about that is how do you get that DNA
into the cell to be start with in order
to get your structures labeled with the
fluorescent proteins and a really nice
way to do it is to use the backhoe virus
system and it's not it's not actually a
viral infection because it's an insect
virus so it's non-toxic to selves
it's it's labelled biosafety level one
so if you're doing self culture you can
do this and it's not replicating in
mammalian cells but what it does is it
delivers the DNA into the cell but then
the DNA has a mammalian promoter so the
virus the back live iris is not able to
replicate and the expression of the
fluorescent protein targeted to these
various structures is driven by FML and
promoter and it's really nice because
you can have a really nice rate of
expression and traditionally hard to
translate primary cells stem cells
neurons and you basically pipette it
into yourself so your plate of cells and
you wait you incubate it overnight and
then by the next day you should have
labeled structures and sometimes it does
take a little titration right that goes
back to optimizing your label for your
specific cell type and so what we're
showing here though is that you get a
really nice high rate of transduction
with different targeted GFP tubulin
mitochondrial in early early endosome
and then on the right there we're
showing just different traditionally
difficult to transfer
cell lines that show nice bright signals
you can see hippocampal neurons so we
talked about reagents a little bit and
reagent selection we we talked about
different questions you can ask of
yourselves and we talked about media
two immature souls in and vessels that
could help cut down on your background
fluorescence sometimes you do all of
that and you still have a signal that's
being very challenging and it's really
hard to see above all the background
there are products like this one
it's backdrop it's a background
suppressor and it works as a chemical
filter to suppress the fluorescence
outside a cell so so this reagent is
just intended for live cells it's only
intended for internal targets and you
have to kind of be brave when you use it
because when you drop it into your your
media it will change the color of your
media it's basically a chemical filter
on your media but you have to keep going
and out enough because if you stop
halfway it actually just makes the
background hoarse but if you add enough
in the channel you want to suppress your
background you will be pleasantly
surprised and you can kind of see that
in the bottom panel there with the plus
sign and that's where in the cows that
calcium is a green fluorescent so it
says that the the cell is alive as us
one of those indicators we talked about
earlier and you can see that the
background has decreased and so now it's
darker and in the minor tract of red
when they use the red channel background
suppressor they've made it so you can
actually see those those healthy
mitochondria being labeled and then in
the blue channel again you can see that
it cuts way down on the background
hopefully you can still see that the
nuclei are labeled and on your computer
screen so that's something that you
would use for live cell and live cell
imaging for to to reduce your background
if you're having problems with
background and you're doing fixed cell
imaging then a possible thing to do if
you've exhausted everything else is to
look into using signal enhancer that's
one of those Reddy probes reagents I
talked about earlier that's in a dropper
bottle and you put
on your fix temper themselves before the
blocking or you could you actually use
it after the blocking as well but
generally we recommend you put it on
before you do your block paint step and
you would see you'll see some help there
where it'll reduce the background by
quite a bit and it might be then you
might be able to actually see those
dimmer signals so then while we're
talking about fixed sells another common
problem that I mentioned earlier is that
when you are doing your imaging
experiment you may have noticed that you
can sometimes see what we refer to as
photo bleaching and it's kind of related
to photo toxicity but instead of the
light causing problems first the cells
I'm causing them to die the light
actually causes the floor for to dim and
and that's from you know the the the
molecule can only floor us so many times
and and so then when the light is shone
on it for too long or too many times it
starts to dim and what you can do to get
around that in your fixed time for
themselves is to use a mounting media
that has anti fades in it which prevent
fading or photo bleaching and one that's
pretty nice to use is prolonged Diamond
and the nice thing about it is it is
that it also preserves the GFP signaling
cells and you can see that in that
middle panel there that the GFP signal
doesn't go away through repeated scans
and it stays nice and bright because
it's protected along with other and
fluorophores as well so that can be
something to look at using if you're
running into problems with photo
bleaching and your fix and firm cells if
you have issues excuse me if you have
issues during live cell imaging it's a
little trickier because a lot of those
anti
is that prevent photo blue-jean also can
be very toxic to cells but there are
there is something that we offer are
called prolong live as opposed to
prolong Dimond which i just mentioned
and it's to help with photo bleaching in
a lifestyle experiment and what you can
see here is that this HeLa cells are
expressing mitochondria that's been
labeled with GFP and you can see that
the prolong live in the media will help
prevent that GFP from photo bleaching
compared to clip complete media shown
underneath and it basically increases
the amount of time that you can image
your GFP expressing cells live cells by
about 50% so um I hope that this seminar
has been helpful if you want similar
information and information about
reagent and protocols we do offer some
free apps for your for your mobile
devices and I'm showing you the URL at
the bottom there or you can just search
cell imaging in the application stores
and then another resource that's there
for you is @ww mo Fisher com backslash
imaging basics and that's that has a lot
of information some of it I've covered
here about different things if you're
new to fluorescent imaging that that you
might want to know about and so that's
that's there to use and with that I'll
go over the key takeaways and so keys to
successful imaging experiments the
practical considerations that the title
alluded to reduce your background do
everything you can to make your signal
high and your background low and and if
you make that you know the signal that
you
which is what you want to see in the
background which you don't want to see
fluorescently labeled as as big as
possible you'll have the best outcome
for your experiment you also if you're
doing live cell imaging you need to keep
yourselves really happy with
environmental controls because you can't
just pop them on that icy bicycle and
expect them to pedal away and then
lastly you want to pick bright
fluorophores that give you a nice bright
signal so that you can use as little
light as possible for excitation and
then you want to excite at the most
optimal wavelength for the floor for
you're using which means match your
filters to your floor floor make sure
your instruments functioning properly
and with that all closed and I believe
that you can ask questions in the in the
Q&A and thank you for attending you
could make questions by typing them into
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
our first question which of these
regions would work in tissues that's
always a very common question and just
like most of biology the answer is it
depends which is never what people want
to hear but it really depends on what
reagent you are looking to use some of
them can work well in tissue and it's
really going to be tissue dependent the
one that always works in almost every
tissue that people have tested it in
click it edu and click it plus those are
are the things that label proliferation
and those work very well in tissue other
other dyes that we mentioned here like
the trackers and things like that
it'll be really dependent on the tissue
itself I think the question was does
cell event come in any color besides
green and the answer is unfortunately no
not right now
cell event is the the probe that was for
caspase activity in the ape atonic
pathway and we really we we know that
our customers really want it in other
colors and the chemists and biologists
here at molecular probes are working as
hard as they can and as soon as we have
something that we think does a good job
we will be selling it but right now the
the one that works the best is just
available in the green color
great I would like to once again think
- Liam black my furher presentation do
you have any final comments no I don't
have any final comments just be sure to
check out those web resources and you
can always call customer support that
phone number was given in the beginning
of the slide if you have questions about
molecular approach products you will
receive an email from laberd's alerting
you when this webcast would be available
to replay we invite you to forward that
announcements to your colleagues may
have missed today's live event see you
next time and goodbye
you